Il direttore è lì della scuola sta
dormendo
Ti ho preso sono di nuovo in prigione
questa volta c'è imprigionato questa
persona che si chiama girl in realtà lo
scrive c'è scritto di scappare dalla
scuola di Gary ma non è una scuola è una
prigione forse una prigione scuola
Esatto Ho una scuola prigione aiuto ma
soprattutto Guardate evitare laggiù Lo
vedete mi sto rilassando nel frattempo
Boh vabbè voi come sempre Mettetevi
comodi Presi i Popcorn lasciate un bel
mi piace iniziamo subito la nuovissima
attenzione perché oltre alla versione
normale c'è la ventosa la la ventosa
la persona è spaventoso
spaventoso quindi curiosa di provare la
versione spaventato
Wow
quindi si vedono solo delle frecce
illuminate
Ma non si può entrare in queste porte
qui c'è il basilico Guarda stanno
facendo il basilico
e devo controllare qui seguiamo queste
frecce Anch'io sto controllando tutte le
porte Magari riusciamo a volte tutte
chiuse
ho trovato la via d'uscita
sì forse no bisogna prendere troppo
facile Ah ok Non l'avevo visto che
bisognava prendere Oh aspetta aspetta
non mi lasciare qui nel labirinto Ok mi
ripeto
Ok non riesco a passare Rita Aiutami dai
sbrigarmi non riesco ad aprire la porta
ce l'ho fatta Ok
Che è successo a primo sfracellamento mi
sa che anch'io mi sono stufato
dove sei Sono caduto adesso
Allora devo prendere la rincorsa e
saltare di là forte uh Ciao ciao Io sono
già arrivata qua Allora c'è un pulsante
qua pronti premiamo Uh Che cosa è
successo si sono attivate tipo Oh non mi
spingere No aspetta si è spostata Quella
quella cosa lì ma dobbiamo saltarci
sopra che c'è mi sono sfracellato No io
ti vedo ancora vivo okay okay okay okay
l'ho preso io il passaggio E adesso come
faccio io eh eh Mi dispiace ma non puoi
più passare No non è certo che puoi
passare lo stesso se non si disattiva
e vi piace il mio outfit di oggi è un
po' ispirato a Sailor Moon ma versione
rosa con due Fiocchetti Rossi Che ne
pensate eh eh
pronto Ora
nei lati Perdi come questa è vero guarda
io già vado di qua si può dare io dico
sono uscita fuori dal gioco un attimino
lì si vede il mio fiocchetto bisogna
saltare qui un caffè figo siamo tornati
indietro tipo dove siamo finiti tu sei
tornato indietro Hai sbagliato ma che ho
sbagliato Guarda sono qui No siamo
tornati a scuola Guardalo lì lo vedi chi
vieni no vero Ah ah eccolo No non farti
vedere vai piano
h mi sono fermato Aspetta aspetta
sta controllato quando si sposta
passiamo ma non prima Ok perfetto
Allora ero quasi riuscito a prendere la
chiave però mi ha preso
aiuto aiuto
aiuto amici
aiuto!
forse è meglio correre senza saltare
le hai lì dentro cioè Mister Gary ha
anche un figlio eh eh
eh Allora vediamo come
Ah che Buffa Mi ha ripreso Allora
vediamo se riesco forse ho capito È
troppo vicino
chiave chiave chiave chiave
Ti ho visto che non c'è più guarda
guarda non ci credo mi sta inseguendo
Lasciami in pace Oh
Ma quale idea
Invece io sto provando a correre intorno
qui a queste classi in modo tale che
magari lui si rallenta un po'
No forse io ce la faccio forse io ce la
faccio Aspetta che lui si nasconde
dietro la chiave sta urlando qualcosa
[Musica]
vada vada
no
ti ha preso dopo non ci credo Devo
rifare tutto da capo perché non hai
salvato ma non potevo salvare altrimenti
sì che avrei salvato Oh io ho aperto là
ho aperto la porta e il problema è che
ora deve riuscire a sopravvivere quale
porta la prendo la porta blu i bagni ti
ricordi che c'era questa cosa del bagno
Uh bisogna entrare nel bagno sì sì sì sì
sì forse forse sono riuscito a scappare
da ieri uh uh Guarda è aperta adesso
perché non è andata troppo prima
lui non può entrare nel bagno delle
femmine ah ah aprilo Guarda apriamo
Perché non si apre quella blu allora eh
Aprite la porta Oh aiuto No mi sto
inseguendo Aprite Vai Aiuto Aiuto
aiuto!che Mi sono nascosta Io ho preso
la porta dei maschi però adesso non
sotterraneo c'era una via d'uscita Sì sì
qua dentro deve andare vai vai
uscita vediamo Ti aspetto Non so se
siamo nello stesso posto
da un altro tunnel ma tu i maschi ed
ecco qua che ci aspetta
bello Ehi dove sei tu non lo so Ah sono
caduto Ok ti vedo Ciao attento non
cadere qua giù ma tu sei passato da lì
Certo certo dall'altra parte forse
bisogna passare da qua Allora vediamo
se sto andando nella direzione giusta
scorciatoia Oh forse sì attento ci sono
Uhm Questa era difficilissimo questo
ponte Wow
e aspetta un momento la porta è chiusa
Quindi bisogna prima trovare Ecco c'è un
pulsante qua per il pulsante vediamo
cosa è successo col pulsante ho aperto
la porta Sì
tira fegato
Ok Ah leader
non avevo capito la leva intendeva
Ma insomma Basta che c'è in questa porta
che abbiamo appena aperto ci sono degli
spuntoni terribili col fuoco cioè il
fuoco
non si muovono vero
meno male
no no no no no no no fermo e che robot
non so dove andare No assolutamente no
ho capito forse ho capito Dovevi andare
allora saliamo qua sopra Oh oh oh aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
Ah eccoti Ciao ciao Ok proviamo a
saltare qui di lato e adesso
però dobbiamo provare a salire ancora
più in alto
non so come si fa Come hai fatto a
salire
ma forse dobbiamo andare dall'altra
parte sono caduta già mi stavo
incorrendo davvero aiuto per fortuna non
è riuscita a prenderlo Guardatelo
ascoltate ascoltate Lo sentite
torna nella classe
Ehi ma tu dovresti andare
è passato attenta è passato una palla di
fuoco e te l'ho detto te l'ho detto
prima
tu devi stare attenta Ah c'è anche i
robot
Sì devi andare buttati giù
Ok perfetto Non sto capendo che cosa
devo fare ah ah mi hai spiaccicato
presto presto presto
ok Io sono passato giù mi riporta
indietro Quindi forse bisogna andare qua
sulla strada sbagliata Vediamo se
dobbiamo andare qua
Sì c'è un passaggio per nascondersi ma
bisogna essere super veloci
Ah ci riprovo dove qui trovato
Sei riuscito a nasconderti bravissimo e
adesso dove sarà l'altro di qua
Aiuto c'è l'altro passaggio credo sia
l'ultimo
ma qui c'è proprio un corridoio
ci sono ovviamente ho fatto il continuo
delle Escape Room allora
oppure no Non lo so
dobbiamo andare sia Il nascondiglio di
un drago questo
drago Non lo so basterebbe bellissimo
cioè sai che cosa sarebbe bellissimo un
piatto di pasta c'è una fame
ma che cosa c'entra adesso
le tubature qua sotterranei un cartello
credimi del Castello non c'è niente da
mangiare non c'entrano con i draghi ho
capito è un labirinto ha creato un
labirinto questa volta è più difficile
del fatto così io inseguo Te Perché io
ne ho idea di chi mi perdo ma anche io
mi perdo non so dove andare Ah ah ah no
tranquilla ma no pure a me m'ha preso
via via via via via
non ci credo che siamo riusciti a
tornare indietro
ma io riesco sempre a essere spiaccicato
da questa Ah Ehi dove sei purtroppo mi
ha spiaccicato quella palla di fuoco e
adesso non riesco più ad andare avanti
perché mi prende sempre
cercando di trovare
un obiettivo Davvero Sì c'è una freccia
gialla Quindi immagino che sia la parte
giusta dove andare allora adesso mi
aiuti per il labirinto perché io non so
dove andare eh Ho paura che se torno
indietro mi perderò Vabbè un pochino più
a trovare la via d'uscita quindi
facciamo che io mi metto qua e salto
così se mi vedi i passi di qua Eccomi
qua dovete raggiungervi presto così vi
volevo Escape Room vediamo
siamo tornati in classe questa Escape
Room è un mix tra una prigione un
castello e una scuola ok ma questa è la
mensa ci sono da mangiare qui Ah Ah
guarda
credo di sì in effetti
c'è una pizza una pizza dei panini
panini
Bisconti Ok io basta la via Escape Room
finisce qui Ciao
perché è chiuso qua Mi dispiace per
quello niente eh Continuiamo con
l'escape Room allora eh Per fortuna non
c'è Gary qua e arriverà Secondo me
arriverà presto Ancora no Oh guarda la
super velocità
dobbiamo andare ah ah prendi una lattina
per diventare super
[Musica]
Vitale stava provando a fare meditazione
Ma sei sbattuta la sedia ah ah Guardate
è troppo strano come corre ah ah corri
corri corri corri corri senza gomiti
anche il tuo personaggio corre così poi
si sposerà anche il mio Il problema è
che il mio corre Ma non si muove guarda
cioè c'è qualcosa che non va e corre da
fermo praticamente
attento qua è molto più difficile
forse il doppio salto devo fare Eh no
Devi solo stare attento a prendere un
po' di ri
c'è un problema qua ehm Una volta che
arrivi alla fine non c'è nessun punto in
cui andare Ah figo forse devo saltare di
là ma non ci arrivo cioè proviamo via
Ah che succede Anita quando arrivi alla
fine non c'è nessun punto in cui saltare
una trappola di ieri o forse dobbiamo
controllare meglio Dov'è il punto in cui
saltare perché non c'era niente aiuto
Ok ragazzi allora sono riuscita a
tornare nel punto in cui ero prima però
devo riuscire a capire dove devo saltare
perché
che è successo Adesso l'ho visto siccome
era buio non lo vedevo c'è una
piattaforma lo
mancavano rifare tutto adesso
Ok ragazzi a passare quella parte ora
l'ultimo salto vero
è stato difficilissimo questo qua no si
devono aspettare sulle scale ok E ora
incontreremo dottor Gary Oh come si
chiama Sì
Che cos'è questo laser blu
[Musica]
Un due tre stella solo che io non vedo
non vedo chi è che sta controllando
siamo nel campo da calcio vedi il
Capodanno
lo vedete e lui Mister gare gigantesco
ora si gira dall'altra parte
inquietante Mister Games
Ehi ma mi sta Chiariamo una gonna Come
sei vestito ma vabbè
ce l'hai fatta brava
non mi puoi fare più niente da qua ciao
ciao non mi puoi fare niente Ah ah ah
eccomi finalmente possiamo tornare a
scuola che cosa ho trovato una scala qui
forse forse no non ci serve no che cosa
dice un distributore di bibite carta
chiave Io la prendo
e poi dice di premere Qua
rigenera che cosa è successo Ti dà la
vita forse Ok continuiamo
E come faccio a salire qua sopra
e poi salire qui forse boh non dobbiamo
prendere ho capito
ssima Sei riuscita a prenderla certo
Ehi Dammi la scala No no non quella
normale torna indietro Ok dove c'è il
pulsante di Jenna dietro
ok E poi si sale
Ma come faccio a salire
Uh che figo e sei riuscito a salire più
o meno sbatte la testa al muro OK
riproviamo una alla volta allora
Ok arrivo ho messo la chiave e ora
che cosa è apparsa una scritta ma non ho
fatto niente palle a leggere tu sei
riuscita a leggere quando c'era scritto
no Sono ancora bloccato qui sto cercando
di salire
Ok Ci sono quasi carta chiave necessaria
ok
E adesso passiamo sopra Oh Che figo
attivato dice
Oh che posto Strano no le punte
gelato di nuovo
No non ce l'ho fatta Ok mi ha aiutato
Vitale adesso non riuscivo a passare
quel pezzo era difficilissimo Ora siamo
entrati anche un'altra giocatrice che
dice rigen poi oh che cosa forse ci
servono queste per passare dobbiamo
costruire un ponte Hehe Ma lo devi
costruire devi buttare dentro Allora
mettiamo il primo pezzo qua ma poi
prendiamo un altro pezzo ok Mi ha
buttato a terra i pezzi forse la la la
ragazza lì eh forse era arrabbiata che
l'hai superata Ok prendiamo un altro
pezzo di Ponte Allora credo che bisogna
farlo uno alla volta altrimenti si
diventa Super difficile Ok Ci siamo in
tanti
solo un pezzo
e
prima ho preso questo pezzo di Ponte
sopra c'era la giocatrice Forse per
quello che è arrabbiata
Allora riprovo io adesso ok poi
prendiamo un altro pezzo di Ponte lo sai
che se io clicco questo pulsante
spariscono tutti i pezzi tu non lo
cliccherai Vero vero
evitare che cade giù No già così son
messo male davvero Poverino Dai non
clicchiamo non clicchiamo Ma perché c'è
una scatola da portare qua uhm Ah
dobbiamo mettere la scatola qua non
capisco perché me li mette tutti storti
questi ponti non fa niente Tanto riesce
a passare lo stesso ma in realtà mi sono
sfracellato cioè 15 volte Beh dai questa
era la parte più facile era più
difficile quella di prima ok scusami Ce
l'ho fatta Allora dobbiamo metterlo
subito e poi sali sopra saliamo sopra la
scatola figo
eh Siamo tornati a scuola non so se
riesco a salire sulla scala Ehi Guardate
quando è stato tipo dei tatuaggi sotto
le braccia Allora vedete Uh Che strano
Allora qua c'è una porta sbarrata così
dovremmo andare in questa
e adesso tutto tutto tutto Uhm che cos'è
questo Oh Che cos'è il direttore
della scuola sta dormendo
cerchiamo di Non svegliarlo Ok non so
cosa dobbiamo fare
il righello tipo Allora forse ho capito
Dobbiamo trovare una via d'uscita qui da
qualche parte
anch'io per capire cosa devo prendere ma
fanno rumore basta basta
qualsiasi cosa clicchi fa rumore apposta
per svegliare gay Dobbiamo capire cosa
serve allora
Guarda che ho spostato la libreria ma
non è successo niente
deve esserci un passaggio assolutamente
non sei neanche svegliato
Ci deve essere qualche segreto qua c'è
un altro passaggio segreto No no no
scappa scappa Oh no E quindi dove
dobbiamo andare credo che sia l'unica No
no no ci stai seguendo sono rimasta
bloccato no ecco non lo vedo bisogna
nascondersi Mi ha preso Aiuto aiuto
ma quanti giri ci sono qua Ci sono
tantissimi
non hai la chiave della biblioteca
quindi ci vuole la chiave della
biblioteca ok Sì dobbiamo Eccola l'ho
trovata dov'era e nel tavolo dellaggiù
in fondo nel tavolo laggiù in fondo Ok
Provo a cercarla prova
perché l'ho messa più di lato forse
aiuto che non si apre la porta Sto
arrivando Chéri
c'è qualcosa che non va forse non è
questa la porta o no non è questa la
chiave è l'unica porta Oh no dai madre
si fa a fare
bravo Ce l'hai fatta bisognava togliere
la chiave
sali qui apriamo il bottone per salire
su
mi sta piacendo un sacco credo che siamo
vicini alla fine però purtroppo
dovremo affrontare ieri Ora ora
di nuovo dove sfida finale
siamo tornati nel castello Certo che è
proprio strana questa cosa e qui c'è Mmm
vabbè una specie di scala non lo so
proviamo ad andare qui super velocità di
nuovo dove dobbiamo andare uh uh
e guarda è volato Guarda io anche
porcone
non c'è gravità qua
è sbagliato Ok dobbiamo salire qua ti
arriverà prima il Belgio deve arrivare
prima allora
morta
e adesso no
mmm
Forse perché è una sorta di labirinto
anche qua Forse dobbiamo cercare delle
chiavi Non lo so ma c'è molto silenzio
il che mi fa sospettare che cosa oh oh
oh ferma tecnica del signor Gary lei
lanciatore Sì dobbiamo Oh dobbiamo
prendere il signor guerrieri Beh colpa
tua devi uscire fuori dalla scuola aiuto
Ok ti credo o no Gary sta cercando di
prendermi Quindi ora devi sì da quello
che trovate lì Brava c'è la sfida finale
comunque è gigante Devi selezionare il
lanciatore che sarebbe la zucca ah ah
non riesco a vedere Gary mi sta
lanciando un panino
facilissimo ma come si muove che cos'ha
il fatto dei piedi Che cos'è quello no
Devo trovare il modo di colpirlo da
un'altra parte sono riuscito a prenderlo
solo una volta e non sbaglio sto
lanciando dei panini Io sì
quindi questa è l'arma perfetta per
Vitale
No è difficilissimo devo andare a
nascondermi da qualche parte però forse
sta andando abbastanza lento lui Insomma
stai riuscendo a prenderlo
stai riuscendo a prenderlo Diciamo che
sto correndo sono tipo a metà se lo
elimino prima io prenderò il badge prima
di Vitale
ancora non
non mi ha aperto Allora proviamo tecnica
[Musica]
mi ha lanciato un sega rotante aiuto che
paura è un laser
aiuto Allora forse ci riesco aiuto
Secondo me è l'unico modo è nascondersi
da qualche parte e colpirlo Dio nascosti
ci ho provato lo sai ma non ci riesco
aiuto
io mi metto qua sopra riuscirà a
prendermi
non riesco più a vederlo dai ieri
Smettila di dire trinciarmirmi
adesso ti trasforma il panino Sì molto
probabile
è difficilissimo perché l'hanno fatto
così difficile no Forse ce l'ho fatta
Forse ce l'ho quasi fatta non ci credo
sì ce l'ho fatta e ho preso il peggio
Beh ora devo riuscirci anche io devo
riuscirci
è troppo difficile mi sta incollato Beh
io sparo Eh guarda se fare panini lo
colpisco lo stesso Pensavo che dovessi
sempre mirare insomma eh girarmi e
mirarlo bene
qui vicino a te e tutto il supporto
morale mi vedi
dietro di te non riesco mai a colpirlo
sto solo scappando se non mi elimina
Allora ti dirò qualche panino anche a te
ti piace
e tu mi dai sì ti vedo Peccato che sono
colpisci tu non gli va dietro neanche
ah ah Vai via Cheri sei riuscita no mi
ha spedito da qualche parte proviamo con
la difficoltà di forse più facile eh
di cosa mi ha sparato ti ha buttato un
martello tipo aiuto dai devi scappare
spara ogni tanto Ok
Oh che paura vai vai vai vai vai vai a
metà
[Musica]
devi puntare su di lui però eh la
freccia la devi puntare su di lui
altrimenti non lo prendi dai scappa
Aiuto No non ci credo non sto riuscendo
manca poco dai c'hai la vite rossa così
piccola Dai ancora due colpi
Bravo bravo Ce l'hai fatta anch'io
[Musica]
Sì e poi Dove bisogna andare finito così
possiamo andare in giro per il campo qui
aspetta prima ho visto un'aria che è
chiusa con con delle cose luminose Ecco
Quella giù vedi Seguitemi
forse
adesso è aperto Sì aperto siamo matti
ora che abbiamo vinto lì ci sono i vari
pulsanti per correre velocissimo saltare
vero
oh oh Pure
tu Dominick
Ok prova lucidata Romina siamo qua
quattro caselline su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite eh Buona visione
Ciao